For a moment, we want you to cast your mind
back to your childhood.
A time when you weren’t as busy or burdened
with the pressures of life that come as you
grow up.
When you were carefree and had your whole
life ahead of you, nothing but potential and
opportunity.
A simpler time, when the highest award you
could achieve wasn’t a grade or a promotion,
but something as simple as your mom or dad
pinning a drawing you did to the door of the
refrigerator.
Oh, to be a kid again, right?
Then again, maybe returning to younger days
is better left as a fantasy.
It’s hard to imagine that something so pure,
so simple and wholesome as a drawing on the
fridge could ever be something dark, horrific
even.
But then, you learn about SCP-683, and all
of a sudden returning to your childhood becomes
something you hope never happens.
SCP-683 is an anomaly with various parts to
it, so we’ll start with SCP-683-1.
At first glance, it looks to be just an ordinary
refrigerator; to be more precise, it’s actually
a 1953 Crosley Shelvador, for any of you fridge
experts out there who are curious about the
exact make and model of SCP-683-1.
For everyone else, picture the refrigerator
that Indiana Jones hid inside to miraculously
survive a nuclear blast in Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull.
I don’t know about you guys, but I’m feeling
nervous already.
Like we said, at first glance you’d struggle
to spot anything out of the ordinary about
this particular fridge, apart from maybe some
slight wear and tear on the outside.
Inside though, it’s perfectly clean, kept
in perfect working condition for keeping food
cool.
But that’s the first weird thing about SCP-683-1.
You see, despite the Foundation conducting
tests to deliberately make it messier, the
fridge seems to have an inbuilt function that
you wouldn’t find in one from Home Depot.
It can self-clean.
Yes, that doesn’t sound all that impressive
- unless you’re a fridge owner yourself
and know what a nightmare they can be to keep
clean.
While it’s definitely weird, it’s not
the last of SCP-683-1’s anomalous properties.
The next is the fact that the power cord of
this refrigerator ends with a plug that doesn’t
match any known type of wall outlet.
Seems even stranger, after all, who would
design a fridge that can’t even be plugged
in, right?
In fact, the SCP Foundation had to design
their very own completely one of a kind adapter
to connect SCP-683-1 to an ordinary gas-powered
home generator.
Once plugged in though, SCP-683-1 functions
exactly like you would
expect any other refrigerator
to… sort of.
It’s about time we move on to SCP-683’s
second component, designated as SCP-683-2.
Again, much like the fridge it is somehow
affixed to, at first look this part looks
completely ordinary.
It’s a drawing, created using felt pens
and pencils, presumably by a child between
the ages of five and seven years old.
There’s evidence of some moderate water
damage to the paper, but once again nothing
all that strange to look at.
Even the subject of this child’s drawing
is pretty mundane, just some scribbles of
a pleasant mountainous landscape, a house,
a well, a dog, a figure wearing a chef’s
toque and, of course, an anthropomorphic sun
with a smiley face.
Now sure, that might not
sound all that impressive,
but we would advise not to say anything like
that out loud.
Criticizing the drawing is a comment you might
wish you hadn’t made, just like when you
fill our comment sections with dated Among
Us memes.
Any person that makes any kind of negative
or disparaging remark about the SCP-683-2
drawing, or tries to remove the paper from
the fridge door of SCP-683-1 will suffer a
grim, horrific fate.
The next time they try to eat anything, this
person will suffer immense, irreparable damage
to their internal organs, along with their
skin and muscle tissue.
This is intensely painful, causing the subject
agonizing pain as their organs and skin are
melted down.
The amount the person loses is equal to the
mass of food they’ve eaten; with each bite,
they will lose more and more of their body.
The painful process will not stop until they
have ingested 0.42 kilograms of food.
Making this even worse, the process doesn’t
seem to target any organs that would kill
the subject immediately.
They’re made to suffer in excruciating pain,
punished with torture for daring to try and
remove the drawing from the fridge.
Any and all subjects will die within twenty-six
days of taking that final bite and thus losing
the last piece of themselves.
But, where do the body parts of these people
go?
Surely, they don’t disappear, you must be
thinking.
And you’d be right.
In instances like this, the mystery third
component of SCP-683 is revealed.
Referred to as SCP-683-3, a brown paper lunch
bag will manifest inside the SCP-683-1 fridge,
containing a grim and grizzly assortment of
meals.
On every occasion, the bag contains a sandwich,
with a pretty disgusting filling: the flesh
and viscera of the last person who dared to
criticize the drawing on the refrigerator.
There is also a plastic ziploc bag, in which
you’ll find the other half of the stolen
organs and flesh of this unlucky person, along
with three chocolate chip cookies.
Surprisingly, these are actually completely
normal cookies with no traces of DNA or other
abnormalities to them.
Every time, there is also one final item that
forms the contents of SCP-683-3, and that’s
a note which reads “Be a good boy today”.
This note bears the same handwriting as appears
on the outer surface of the paper bag, upon
which a single name is written: Eric.
Now, for those of you in the know about the
various anomalies of the SCP Foundation, that
particular, unassuming name might sound very
familiar.
It was the same name mentioned by another
anomaly, known as SCP-066.
A brief bit of context for you, SCP-066 was
a living ball of yarn that displayed friendly
behavior towards Foundation staff.
However, during an experiment, a thread was
cut from SCP-066’s body.
This caused the yarn to transform into a ball
of meat, with a pair of functional eyes protruding
from it.
SCP-066 became hostile, constantly asking
for an ‘Eric’ whenever someone gets too
close to it.
The same name, Eric, was also found carved
into the back of SCP-168, another anomaly
encountered by the SCP Foundation.
SCP-168 was an anomalous calculator, which
actually possessed some level of sentience
and had the ability to communicate.
So, who is Eric?
Well, theories range far and wide, but there’s
no real definitive answer as to exactly who,
or what Eric might be.
Some claim he’s a reality-bending entity,
others posit he’s an SCP that the Foundation
just doesn’t know about yet.
Regardless, he’s connected to some intriguing
entities; a sentient calculator, a formerly
friendly ball of yarn, and a fridge with a
child’s drawing on it that can steal people’s
organs and put them in a lunch bag especially
for him.
It would seem that Eric is a child, maybe
a schoolboy, possibly even the one responsible
for the drawing on SCP-683.
This child could even potentially be anomalous
in nature.
Of course, this is all just rampant speculation
on our part, so it’s probably best to take
all of that with a grain of salt.
As we’ve said before, it’s just a theory
- an SCP Explained theory.
Eric might just remain one of the Foundation’s
many unanswered mysteries for years to come.
But if that answer doesn’t satisfy you,
then why don’t we go back to SCP-683.
Maybe something in the fridge’s origin will
give us a further clue to the mystery of who
Eric is.
The fridge was first discovered by the SCP
Foundation in the storage unit of a Washington
home, owned by a woman named Yolanda.
As coincidence would have it, Yolanda was
a collector of vintage home furnishings, including
refrigerators, which would probably explain
why she didn’t think to throw out such an
old model of fridge from the 1950s.
According to her, she found SCP-683 simply
left on a nearby street corner, with nobody
around that could have left it there, or anyone
that could have possibly been transporting
it to the local dump.
To give her a hand moving the fridge, Yolanda
enlisted the help of her nephew, who agreed
to step in and assist her in getting SCP-683
back to her house.
Unfortunately, though, the nephew passed away
only two weeks later, apparently due to medical
complications that came as the result of a
hernia according to his death certificate.
Could Yolanda’s nephew have been the mysterious
and elusive Eric?
Could something have happened to him after
his death that allowed him to become some
kind of anomaly?
Who’s to say, we can only guess and hope
that one day we might get a full answer.
As to why Yolanda never suffered the effects
of SCP-683, she never actually tried to take
the SCP-683-2 drawing down from the fridge.
When asked why, she simply replied “It’s
a nice little picture, isn't it?
Why take it down?”
Maybe, just maybe, it might have even reminded
her of her nephew.
It would have been a futile and foolish idea
for Yolanda to have even tried to remove the
drawing at any rate, as any who try will suffer
that painful and horrifying process of losing
their organs and having them appear in Eric’s
paper lunch bag.
Even fire can’t remove the drawing from
the fridge, at least not permanently, suggesting
that even the paper it is drawn on has its
own anomalous properties.
On three separate occasions, the SCP Foundation
has attempted to test this, setting SCP-683-2
on fire with nothing more than a match.
Every time, the drawing was incinerated, burned
to ashes until there was nothing left.
But, within sixty-eight hours, SCP-683-2 had
returned to its permanent fixture on the fridge
door, as if nothing had happened.
Interestingly though, the D Class members
of personnel that were instructed to burn
the drawing didn’t suffer the usual anomalous
effects of SCP-683.
A similar thing happens if multiple people
attempt to remove SCP-683-2 or say anything
negative towards the drawing.
In cases like this, only the very first person
who made a disparaging remark, or tried to
rip the drawing from the fridge will be the
one to suffer a long, painful torture by organ
removal, followed swiftly by death.
Now, if you cast your mind back to earlier
in the video, we told you that someone who
tries removing or disparages SCP-683-2 will
only suffer an anomalous lack of organs when
they next eat something.
So, you must be thinking that the way to avoid
that is to simply not eat, to fast, and not
ingest a single meal.
And yes, you’d be right, that does stave
off the anomalous effects of the fridge and
the drawing, but also means you’re heading
towards an even slower, painful death from
starvation.
To date, two different Foundation test subjects
have died this way by refusing to eat after
interacting with SCP-683.
True, the SCP Foundation is most likely sitting
on a whole cavalcade of different anomalies
that can keep a person alive without the need
for food, but you know what they’re like,
right?
The Foundation’s hardly likely to share
the keys to surviving without having to eat.
And there you have it, folks, that’s SCP-683.
Don’t worry, it’s highly unlikely that
you’ll ever encounter it.
The Foundation keeps it under lock and key,
in a cell fitted with a steel door and reinforced
hinges.
SCP-683 remains covered in a large cloth to
prevent any members of personnel from looking
at it when the fridge isn’t being used for
research or experiments.
But you have to wonder, what if it’s not
the only fridge with these anomalous properties?
After all, it’s rare for a manufacturer
to make just a single refrigerator of a certain
model.
Maybe you’d better be wary next time you
visit someone with an older model of fridge
in their kitchen, and just to be safe, if
there’s a drawing pinned to the front door,
leave it where it is.
Now go check out “Killer Living Graffiti
SCP-1155 - Predatory Street Art” and “Living
Drawing SCP-085 - Hand Drawn Cassy” for
more art that really jumps off the page!